flat for is making an appearance in rock
band for a ball games soon you can get
your jam on while wearing the functional
and fashionable vault 111 jumpsuit
complete with the pip-boy that pulses to
the music Harmonix announced a
partnership with Bethesda to bring the
fallout 4 outfits to the game so prepare
your brain for the anachronisms now
because watching animated folk-singing
21st century tunes while wearing outfits
from the 1950s that were then worn again
in 2287 is about to get real convoluted
you can pick up the blue and yellow
outfits for free starting to send the
eighth from the in-game store disclaimer
for the outfits reads rock out in
post-nuclear style note search provides
no protection against radiation and any
liability cannot be held against
vault-tec industries or its subsidiaries
rock band 4 is the latest weird place
fallout 4 is shown up after previously
appearing in forza 6 and rocket league
let me know if you won't fall out for
invading any of your other games and
which ones keep it tuned to gamespot for
all the latest
you